not SMI Anthony Edwards text message
leak it's none of our damn business so
um ESPN Express is concerned uh Stephen
A Smith over the controversy involving
Minnesota timber star Anthony Edwards
listen I know there's not a big Sports
audience out there but this is actually
a uh cultural conversation about
abortions what's going on with probably
one of the leading MV MVP candidates in
the NBA right now Anthony Edwards who
was the best player on the uh USA team
over the summer uh in the in the world
thing to Michael Jordan in the NBA right
now yeah okay not even tell me who today
tell me Oh I thought you said he is my
bad he is he is the closest thing to
Michael Jordan in the game today today
there is no too soon to be talking like
that but give me a name of somebody in
the NBA today that's got the closest
game to Michael today game style there's
no not any it would probably be him I
mean obviously it's he's a poor man's
Jordan but I who do you put ahead of I
don't put anyone I don't like that
comparison style I don't mean to offend
it's just anyway friend how could I live
that's the one thing she got offended by
today Free Speech absolutist but don't
call don't question Michael Jordan so
he's facing backlash because uh um
private text messages were leaked
revealing that he encouraged an abortion
um with this girl that he was casually
dating and he sent her a hundred grand
she was an Instagram model so you can
imagine what she looks like um Stephen
asith responds because he does that with
every situation out there let me say
this Anthony Edwards had to apologize
only because he's a public public figure
Smith questioned the repercussions faced
by individuals who exposed private
messages in the public essentially
doxing I'm wondering why some law is
going to come into the place where
people like Anthony Edwards and others
can retaliate legally for folks putting
their private messages on blast it's
none of our business he emphasize that
they need to protect priv privacy rights
in such situations so the story long and
short is he knocked her up she there was
text messages basically saying she's
he's like so what you going to do with
that thing and she and she's like I
don't know she was a horrible here's 100
Grand he's like yeah I have the abortion
she's like $100,000 abortion Jes well
her whole thing was she said that she
had an abortion two years ago um where
it would have been a boy she said I lost
my son um and now I regret it lost lost
him or killed him was two years ago
exactly no no that's what's going on now
but she's telling him the reason I don't
want to get an abortion today is because
that I
got also read the K Playbook it's called
have the child get child support contact
an agent and see if you can get you know
but here's the she we a wedding ring and
her bottom lip was bit by a bee look at
well that you know welcome to Instagram
model life but the reality is he already
sent her the 100 Grand oh okay and then
afterward she starts looking the text
messages what a rookie 50 now 50 later
but I feel bad if this kid ever is born
I mean we're in social media nothing
gets deleted he's going to grow up up
and they be like you know what happened
how why you're alive you know your
father wanted to abort you your mother
this like that's the reality of the
situation today and that's her fault
listen if people want to be pro-life if
people want to be pro-choice cool it's
all good do that behind closed doors but
the fact that you're putting people on
blast and basically sort of like
blackmailing them into disgusting into
making sure that you can have this baby
no wonder iron hates us I'm I'm joking
um it's not funny no but like be being
the only one estrogen in this room I
hope
um sorry no I just think that there's
two separate issues the the morality of
of airing someone's Private Business
which is to me just wrong it's like
clout chasing 101 like this girl's
horrible I think like she's a disgusting
woman and your child's going to be
humiliated that's the point you brought
up but B it's like it's not our business
and then C it's like the only reason
it's an issue is because like you said
it's part of the left agenda like oh
normalize abortion blah blah blah and
she was trying to air that but like I
just think do whatever you want to do
like as someone I think abortion is
horrible and I would never put myself in
a situation to need one I think someone
needs to do a better job talking to
these like why every why are NBA players
always knocking girls up why is this
always a story why does zion have like
eight baby mamas coming out saying oh he
knocked me up too and I got an abortion
like it's really not that hard to not
get someone pregnant in today's day and
age and instead this shit's happening
because people are stupid and chasing
clout you know who you're sleeping with
I'm sorry look how she looks does that
not scream I want to get Knocked Up and
post it and steal your money for the
next 18 years I mean she looks like a
perfectly classy girl what are you
talking I saw a girl like that at church
on Sund I saw that same exact look at
church I'm going to
get you're asking why by the way she may
qualify for two seats on
Southwest look at that there you go yes
no right you can't fit that in one
that's called a twofer and and maybe
what she's saying is they need to change
like can you imagine like if they Staple
Center or some of these Arenas they
change their name welcome to the Trojan
Center uh they got they got to do it
they got to do Magnum Center Trojan
Magnum Center Trojan Center you ask you
ask why these guys knock these girls up
I mean you know that I've have friends
in the NBA and I've been around this
world there's something called uh Jersey
Chasers or Cleat Chasers or Jersey
jumpers or homy Hoppers this their
business model they're hot they're
Instagram models are they hot not keep
putting that up way put your pants back
on they might not be your version of hot
but there was a guy that you know called
Sir Mix aot that had a song called Baby
Got Back and he said I want a girl that
got buns son so that's what these guys
are into this these are the Instagram
type models that these NBA guys are
basically surrounding with I get you
know after the game there's called
postgame passes I go down there cuz I've
you know been with friends and do all
that and you see the girls obviously
that are get the postgame passes they're
not the wives they're not the
girlfriends they're these girls they get
a couple extra passes after the game you
know uh Anthony Edwards he plays in
Minnesota believe me if he's in Miami or
in Phoenix or Dallas for a couple nights
these girls show up to the game he's
repopulating I'm just I'm just letting
you know he's enjoying his time off I
just don't understand why you don't wrap
it up homie cuz if feel better the other
way that's what're it feels better well
I hope you feel better cut $100,000
checks or you know alimony or child
support Sean Kemp needs to do like a
oneone course and get up there and say
Guys these are how many kids did Sean
Kemp have he had a lot of them I think I
and it and it basically bankrupted him
thanks for looking up homie hopper Rob
see that again Sean Kamp has how many
kids Sean km had one the best that a
chart did I just see a a chart of kids
coming in
you know you're putting in work when
there's a chart
he seven children with six different
women so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right
here